but
we have a special guest in studio i
assume a winner of today's round with
incredible preparation christian take it
away
thank you guys yes we are indeed with
andrew hung after an incredible victory
andrew first of all welcome back to the
studio welcome back to st louis what did
you do in the last year since we've seen
you at the juniors last year um i
haven't done too much honestly i've just
been focusing on college now i'm going
to be a senior next year so that's been
my main focus actually perfect well you
focused on college but you've also
focused on your opening preparation
because today that was just brilliant
tell us a bit about that
um i mean it was just a small idea i had
in this line i just quickly checked it
and um
yeah when i was looking at the position
of the bishop d3 obviously d5 is the
only move but um
tell us a bit about this queen to f2
because this was the novelty right in
the position queen f2 is uh
very nasty because if bishop d7 now
queen d2 and the pawn d6 is hard to
defend
um
so he played principally he must take on
g5 actually and after e5 um
take on g5 and e5 yeah knight e4 is a
massive threat and so take on that force
correct
um 94 leads to draw but um it's actually
black has more options than white so but
here my idea was bishop d3 which is a
quite unpleasant and practical game and
black must find here like d5 is the only
move which
the point is that now 94 doesn't work
because d
rook d8 king g8 uh queen c5 and now 97
and black gets three pieces for the
queen we actually thought this probably
is the variation that you prepared queen
to g1
take on d3 queen takes g7
and then the h pawn goes down the board
but this is not what you breathe no it's
not what i had in mind
little secrets
sure that's what you have in mind i
i mean like i'm sure everyone will run
with the engine so i mean there's
nothing to hide i've heard d5 i just
plan to play rook chu on here g
and what is a lot of compensation it's
still unpleasant so i
i played this idea because i knew even
if he had found d5 i can still continue
playing and obviously he would um be low
on the clock and stuff so but yeah
actually when i finished preparation
like i was taking a shower and then i i
realized oh now i was trying to
calculate f5
because it looks sort of natural for
black but then while i was giving it to
myself as a calculation exercise but i
was thinking like why not just plug into
the computer just scrub calculating just
check wow so you came uh
to the idea of this move f5 in the
shower yeah i was just taking a shower
i thought
what happens on f5 yeah
yeah and i quickly checked this and yeah
this is a brilliant idea just
sacrificing work again i know that yeah
what is um
completely winning here for example like
the line i checked was like queen d4
queen h4
king d7
um
h6 like king c7 i checked um rook t1
uh queen e3 shaq
king b1 now black has like queen h3
which just
looks like it might be holding on but
now queen e7
queen d7
queen f
queen after eight
we have eight
queen d8
wow queen f7 bishop d7 and here a4 is
very strong
okay
get out of here
get out of here
very nice preparation andrew and then
you guys got all the way until the end
of the game with two queens on the board
and this was very visual
take us a bit about uh tell us a bit
about your emotions at that point um
when you played king c6 um i knew it was
completely winning but still had a few
things little things to calculate and
there's many many options so the most
important thing here i was just focusing
on not trying to give up my advantage
somehow so um and i think you made all
the best decisions queen to f6 was a
tremendous move very strong yeah and
this probably ends the game of rook d1
um because h7 gives me some chance but
this is ends the game end
but it was so funny to us that he had to
give up to hunt that knight on c3 just
to try to create the illusion of some
sort of an attack against your king and
it was still you as white with the two
queens creating checkmating threats yeah
it's very key and like in many positions
i all have this resource queen g1 so
i'll be up in materials so whether it's
upper rook or like here with two queens
queen g1 is always on it
extinguishes all his counterplay so
there's nothing here andrew tremendous
game tremendous start for you who do you
have tomorrow um i don't didn't attract
but i think probably bellagio that's my
guess you with the black pieces
white so you are uh the player repeating
yeah i have i took lot one so yeah
actually started too i feel well go get
some rest and we'll see you tomorrow
yeah thank you very much congratulations
andrew indeed
he's the first uh winner of uh our
trinity
the trio what did you call trio of
national championships we came up with
something good i mean now i can't even
quote you properly i don't even remember
it anymore
i mean that was nice but it'll be part
of the senior soon i that will go down
as it's some of the best prep we've ever
seen yeah that was the name here the st
louis chess club fantastic stuff